The film CODA - it's the story of a teenage girl
who has this deaf family.
There's a scene in the film - this school concert
and we get to Ruby's performance and right when you're ready
to hear her we go to complete silence
and shift POVs to this family.
They are starting to look around to get perspective on
you know, is she good? Are people enjoying it?
They go home, they're about to go into the house and
Frank wants a moment alone out on the truck.
Ruby sees that moment, and then Frank asks her,
“That song you sang tonight, what was it about?"
It was about
what it is to need another person.
The lyrics of that song are really, really resonant.
In that moment he says, “Can you sing it for me?"
♫ Like the sweet morning dew ♫
♫ I took one look at you ♫
♫ and it was plain to see you were my destiny. ♫
Frank is trying to understand why...
What is so special about his daughter's singing?
Is there something that Frank is missing?
So I wanted that time to find those moments.
I was grateful that most of the singing, like all of the singing
was live on set because in one of the takes he was like, “More.
Louder!" And I didn't know he was going to do that and so then
I had to sing louder.
So much of it just came alive on set when we were together.
I said Troy, you get Emilia to sing loud enough so that you
can feel something and Emilia, you get him to feel something.
♫ I will go ♫
♫ where you lead ♫
♫ always there in time of need. ♫
In this moment I, as Frank, had to make a big decision.
As her father, do I let her go?
It was so emotional what happened.
It's not that he magically got to have music.
It's that he had a very intimate
connected experience with his daughter.
Of understanding something that she loves.
And he gave her that moment.
She busted into tears and everyone on set busted into tears.
It was a great scene to do because so much changed on the day
and it was kind of we were living it.
♫ All that I need ♫
♫ to get by. ♫